[Music]
selenium grid came into existence in
2008 webdriver was merged with selenium
RC in 2009 so earlier it was psyllium I
see and then they have created the
driver in 2009 they have merged both of
them actually webdriver have come in
2007 he and RC has come in 2000 who
almost in 2004 but in the form of
JavaScript s runner but after that in
2006 it has gone actually and in 2007
the driver has come so they have how you
draw backs of RC so they combined the
marsh both of them and 2009 they have
made it to selenium webdriver early it
was selenium RC in webdriver now they
have merged it and made it to selenium
webdriver then in small 2016 last year
3.0 beta version was released sequence 0
beta version was released but that was a
beta version the actual version was
released in October 2016 and selenium RC
was deprecated with the release of
webdriver 3.0 how is selenium being used
in industry so just adding one more
point in selenium history that is they
have come up to this to the automated
they created the students who dashed
their application which was developed in
vital the application was time and
expense so this is the application in
time and expense application they were
working on that which was developed and
friendly in Python or dhtml
it was from developed in Python dhtml
and then they were having very less
resources they were not having much
budget in the project and they were
following a giant metallurgy and that's
why they thought to automate it and when
more mission was successful they
launched it into the market that's how
this tool has come
I understand today you know we are
covering a lot of kind of a theoretical
part but it is very important to
understand about selenium about its
components about automation what
automate what not automate these are
very important part so that you can
speak or whenever you get you know
whenever you get interviewed or you go
anywhere they will ask you about these
things so how is selenium being used in
the industry it plays a key role in
DevOps so we can just ignore the dev
opposite nam provides faster feedback
and agility why it's a faster feedback
remember I have given you an example
as soon as developer makes any change
automation by currents and they get to
know whether they're you know with what
they have done is correct or not what
they have done is correct or not if
there are more test cases which are
failing now then of course they will
need to check their goal so it provides
faster feedback and it's leti
it provides improved coverage across
platforms so you can run your framework
or scripts on multiple platform or
multiple browsers and mobile device in
terms of quality it helps in parallel
execution as well for the large number
of tests it provides behavior driven
development so if you want so if you are
not aware about behavior on development
I would suggest you to go and explore a
bit about the event driven development
it is a business language which is used
to easily understand these test cases so
just
and layman example you write your
automation script isn't it it is
difficult for a non programmer to
understand if I write it okay if any
rich script or maybe in the Ruby or in
any other language it will be even if
you are you know you are having a
technical background you may understand
or you may not be able to understand it
but if the person is not from the
technical background if the person is
not a programmer then how will the
person come to know whether you have
automated all the test cases or not
whether you have automated all the test
cases or not so if the business wants to
review your desk it says can they review
it if you say that you have done the
automation if you have say if you say
that you are automating the scripts can
they see that in the business verify
that no that's where vdd comes
behavior-driven development and you can
do that using kookabura ng behave these
are the separate tools suppose mobile
test automation along with appium so you
can do mobile testing you can automate
your mobile application using a PM okay
so the features of selenium of course we
have already discussed all these
features let's go edit it you know at
all these features you know in a fast
mode helps to create a robust regression
automation super web application and
mobile application suppose automation
across many browsers
across many browsers and platforms
supports parallel execution using
selenium grid supports head legs
execution of tests yes this is what you
may not be aware of I'll cover that but
now suppose slide bindings for many many
programming languages so if you want to
run your you know automation if you want
to write your scripts in c-sharp Ruby
Python you can do that so that's what it
sees the Bhoots client bindings for many
programming languages and what this
headless execution is okay so let me
tell you that
so headless sexy is running your
automation script without any UI without
any you eye without opening any browser
you can go to you go to google you write
something and search for it without
opening any browser everything happens
on the command prompt you will see the
command prompt you will run your script
and you can see in the Eclipse console
or in the command prompt that you know
it is going hitting the google.com
searching for something and if you want
to fetch some data you can fetch it but
without opening up any browser browser
is just an interface to show you things
are happening but actually you can do
that without any browser as well and
that's what we call headless execution
it is a 50 percent faster but if I talk
about GUI automation this is not useful
for GI automation this is not at all
good a push headless browser or headless
execution is not good but if you just
want to check the functionality is
working buying or not whether two plus
two is equal to four then you can even
use a headless you can do headless
execution rightly mentioned it can be
used for web services as well but
precise actually we can do you know
using phantom genius you are extra
loading something you know you are using
an external light lady but you can do
the web services statistic note using an
external light that is phantoms yes you
can directly use the inbuilt classes of
Java automate API or web services but
this so they are certain up entities I
would say there are many things I have
not used it for web services distant and
I doubt if there is any HTTP method
again for their shitty method if even if
you use phantoms is again Felicia TP
methods will have to rely on Java pluses
hi there if you liked this video
subscribe to the simple learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turner up and get certified click
here